vientos helados Nevadas regiones
azotadas por Los Fuertes vientos a esto
se enfrentan los habitantes del
hemisferio norte en medio del Invierno
Juliette azota España la tormenta
causada por un frente frío procedente
del Ártico que atacará hasta el jueves
ha dejado 30 provincias bajo las nieve
mientras en Estados Unidos una inusual
helada que cubrió el estado de
California dejó a cientos sin
electricidad en Big Bear cayeron hasta
114 centímetros de nieve
Se pinchó un neumático y tuvimos que
cambiarlo pero Ayer tuvimos que dejar
nuestro vehículo en otro sitio esta
mañana cuando nos dimos cuenta que la
rueda estaba pinchada hubo drama drama
drama y ahora estamos corriendo con la
de repuesto y tenemos que esperar porque
el taller al que íbamos y donde nos iban
a ayudar a nuestra trabajando una
advertencia de ventisca permanecía en
efecto para las montañas de San
Bernardino
en Kansas y Oklahoma tornados dejaron
destrucción a su paso vehículos volcados
y una docena de personas quedaron
heridas el servicio meteorológico
nacional con sede Norman Oklahoma Busca
evaluar todo el desastre causado sabemos
de otras áreas donde ocurrieron daños Y
continuaremos inspeccionándolas a medida
que tengamos la oportunidad Si no
podemos llegar a un área inspeccionar
trabajaremos con los administradores de
emergencias locales para evaluar los
daños las tormentas provocaron Vientos
de hasta 112 kilómetros por hora y
cortes de Electricidad debido a la caída
de las redes eléctricas